[Music]
guys we've all been there before
broke penniless destitute without a dime
to your name and no I'm not talking
about paying off your student loans I'm
talking about taking an eco round in
cs:go but just cuz you're strapped for
cash
doesn't mean you can't still stay
strapped that's why this week on top ten
we're counting down the top ten broke as
kills in csgo and as a bonus just for
you they're all aces you guys oh and
before we get started with this list
guys understand we're talking about the
go rounds in general here so that means
whether your economy is non-existent or
you're taking a cold calculated eco for
a full buy later down the road and no
force buys now let's get on with the
videos we're kicking off this list with
a play from epicenter 2018 now Zeus
isn't exactly known for his fragging so
we forgive you if he didn't expect him
to do anything flashy with a57 in hand
but thanks to some carelessness from
hellraisers the igl managed to
single-handedly win this eco round with
the help of a stolen aka or two while
they think about next round it's a fast
being a couple of clean headshots of the
five seven not to mention the upgrade
into the AEK Zeus looking for the fifth
he's gonna drop the first Kalashnikov
and take the second box ik all that
remains now sure unarmed however walks
it just gonna get stampeded now pinched
and pushed he got it
Zeus takes the AC ace big man Zeus
coming in at number nine is big clans
NEX who sees adding Kevlar paled in
comparison to na vi's full by but that
didn't deter NEX who proceeded to take
down Edward pick up his m4 and put down
the rest of the Ukranian squad with time
to spare
next is full of sex does he shuts up
juice it is damn fine all on flaming how
the hell do you turn that around given
the circumstances given if you're about
to go to matagi they were in a triple
Eco situation and he's got all five you
pointed it out yesterday that next has
always been incredible on dust2 duncan
tweeted it Nico's gonna be a wondering
where the hell that next was two years
ago when they were on now sports he's at
29 kills
taking the number eight spot is Majewski
lives up to his namesake at the season
six ESL pro league finals against
misfits full by the Danish writer was
tasked to do some damage with nothing
but a deagle and damage he did actually
hit in the floor man just get with a
second is the doing damage at range okay
magic he's been a bit of a king or with
the pistol Shazam suddenly back against
the wall three players to try and deal
with desperately need support from Shawn
Cara's something gotta find the first
mat it's now left one versus two houses
deadly Deegan hand starts to peek into
this now he's on four has to wait for
the wind he's gonna go ahead and do it
magic wonder fee five with the D gonna
Lee coming in at number seven is an e CS
season 2n a match that saw luminosity
gaming garner a small lead against
immortals that they were looking to
extend even further but unfortunately
for them Phelps had other plans he is
expecting failure in this round and will
try to get some damage so many angles to
be played on the outside by the CTS
yellow on the high ground there oh dear
what what three kills on that stops but
very intelligently him also it's not
over playing their hand and another one
from Phelps looking for the pistol 800
and he gets it as well
Phelps all five kills deagle headshots
all the
a unreal stuff from Phelps what a
statement to send if luminosity have the
strategy in the tactics doesn't matter
our number six play harkens back to
Cajun B's days on Team Dignitas dig had
their backs up against the wall against
fellow Danish squad heroic with nothing
but some upgraded pistols against to aks
to M fours and an AWP and what happens
next is nothing short of godlike pop
takedown at Mattel we saw snappy going
out towards the cannons as well that's
gonna leave a nice wide angle to cover
off the site but it's the USP pushing
out a cajun be finding to in return it
leaves similar one versus three shore
but it's damaged don't let this be 250
hands he may get another year place goes
down that's a gun picked up Cajun beat
he's got four and he's got the poem
Cajun beat but one thing he does not
have his armor has a chance to become an
absolute hero and three sinks he's deep
in the same cage he's gonna watch this
he's standing in the arch he's come in
the opening it's an eight clutch from
Cajun be taking the number five spot on
our list is a straw Lass's Dupree during
IEM katowice 2017 s Grand Finals Dupree
managed to net himself an extra 1500
bucks by absolutely destroying faze clan
with only add Eagle and some Kevlar not
bad for a single round you free to play
it bags could swing back in that
direction because here isn't going to be
pressure but he's you know that Sosa
flashmob people works though limited
vision limited weapons
just as it was to walk events and P to
fifties and they're free with the ace
phenomenal round from him look how good
that's what that third headshot my god
so sick coming in at the number four
spot is bigs Legia who managed to take
down a formidable faze clan at epicenter
2018 down seven rounds on Mirage big had
nothing but pistols against phases full
firepower but with two quick one taps
and an Ag dunk Legia managed to secure
his team the round in it with a kill
like yet nipple line of Eagle show so it
doesn't post CT make that a second leg
Iran form how much room the free he was
to be two quick shots I'm gonna save him
today needs a little bit more does pick
up the AWP of course that can allow them
to solo short and so he does find the
pickle on towards Kerrigan that's three
kills
he's losses people Adia Peaks out with
the AWP got a 5k on what was essentially
unique around picks up the AWP and
finishes off the job incredible stuff
from him showing up when his team really
needs it our number three play takes us
all the way back to ECS season one
ninjas and pajamas were down a map down
on rounds and low on cash against g2
eSports but not low on guts pith went
all the way in this insane one before
snatching the round away from g2 and
netting himself an ace in the process
the last man standing is jumping Pete's
50 Caliphate must be done
if you can get Sookie killed after
bombers wall and now he's got position
here
it's godlike man that was a fantastic
play the a 708 in Kevlar this guy that's
what that's what an IP needed taking the
runner-up spot on our list is relics in
an ESL pro league season three match
enemy were down five rounds and broke as
hell against complexity but with just a
USP in hand and a borough take a relics
managed to take down every single
terrorist in this beastly clutch relics
is actually sitting inside of the smoke
he's gonna pounce now he's gonna come
around the side he actually finds one
can he get a second but he's got an 8k
in his hand
her greta gets a third what a play from
relics can he get a fourth he's gonna go
for the reload and tap the bomb trying
to pull him up he gets the fourth one as
well
Last Man Standing it's gonna be roca
code represented wrong oh my god the ACE
on a USB save one of these that's so
detrimental now for complexity is that's
just gonna turn basically we've gone
from we've gone from enemy having to go
over this screen save and not bring
anything in round 2 now they've
completely upset it sometimes a play is
so beautiful that nothing else needs to
be said about it which is why XMS takes
first place on our list
seriously just sit back and watch XMS go
on to make one of the most legendary
plays in csgo history against King woods
full by it's pretty good the difference
main deal what's gonna happen out here
to help out actually I was gonna let it
go and take all three XMS with the dig
suddenly turns this around though goes
ahead and takes two lives as he shuts
this down does pick up the bomb she gets
the angle happy gonna go down oh this
man is a master the taps right now go
side he gets himself a third three
bullets three kills
now sneaking on fine that's to watch how
he knew that there was a player up here
to what saying oh my god what is wrong
with you he's gonna go ahead and get for
this mine's gonna be fired four bullets
the whole round is actually quite
reasonable in spiro tried to beat it one
in five shots five shots five kills
sorry scream I think he's better at it
than New York XMS just isn't human but I
don't want to changed it in this last
round that's that's about one of the
best aces I've ever seen yeah well guys
that's it for our top 10 list this week
now one thing I want to ask you to do is
hit that like button so you can put this
man's on a full buy because they don't
give me a wardrobe budget here and I
really do need some new gear thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button